it is often said that road to hell is
paved with good intentions and the
events that transpired here in Cuba
during the fifties you probably heard of
the communist revolution that occurred
in Cuba during the 1950's which put
Fidel Castro and his administration into
power
how are you understand why the knots of
history unbounded this way we have to
look at the political and economical
state of Cuba prior to the Revolution as
these are the leading factors in almost
every social upheaval in part Cuba's one
crop economy sugarcane was the reason
for its struggles and when you
considered that almost 90% of that raw
sugar prior to the revolution went into
the USA it is impossible to doubt that
the US hadn't had a full control over
the Cuban economy and even with that it
wasn't just sugar US companies
controlled in Cuba they had their hands
in everything from telephone and
electrical services to railways and even
control of 80% of the arable land with
so much American money invested in Cuba
and makes only sense that the politics
of Cuba were in control of the US as
well this political control came from
the American involvement in the Cuban
independence war known today as the
spanish-american war after it Cuba was
technically free but USA made sure they
could control Cuba through a deeply
corrupt government which could be easily
swayed with money hence as long as US
companies were allowed to continue with
their monopolistic control of Cuban
economy the government officials and
political higher class with close ties
to the USA got richer and richer so much
so that the income per capita in Cuba
rose to be the fifth highest in the
Americas all the world and income
inequality and economic growth were one
of the worst in the Americas 40 percent
of Cubans were either highly
underemployed or unemployed many of them
didn't know how to read and had no
access to clean water it was a very
tough time for an average Cuban to live
in and it was this world that Fidel was
born into and grew up in however if it
didn't have to deal with most of the
struggles of an average Cuban at the
time he was born to one of the few
wealthier sugarcane farmers profiting
off of the unequal trade with the US
nonetheless Castro wasn't a good child
or a student and there
was sent a lot between different schools
around Cuba during which he came into
contact with the average Cuban
struggling to make ends meet
eventually Castro got into the
University of Havana and studied law but
he wasn't a good student and it didn't
seem like he wanted to be he spent most
of his time trying to get involved first
in university politics and then in the
country's politics he got involved with
Orthodox party and passionately spoke
about anti-imperialism rampant
corruption and the distasteful US
control over the entire country
Castro wasn't a communist not yet he
just wanted to see change with that
change never really coming and the
political situation even starting to get
worse first with gangs and violent
clashes in the street and then with the
violent coup of Valencia Batista Cuba
wasn't improving it was getting worse it
was due to all these events that
Castro's thinking became ever more
radical finding answers in the far-left
estai deals of Marxism and Leninism he
started to believe that almost all
Cuba's problems came from the class
struggle and the only hope left to get
rid of it was to world the revolution
with now both parties getting more
violent people had to start choosing
aside whether it be the well-known
corrupt and brutal government of Batista
or the far left proletariat favoring
Castro weighing the choices many Cuban
people and establishments started to
favor Castro newspapers like France a
Libra or the Bohemian the most highly
regarded Latin American newspaper at the
time were all supporting Castro and his
fight against the Cuban dictator
everyone hoping the Castro will bring on
the necessary change that hasn't really
happened ever since the spanish-american
war so when Castro finally managed to
come to power the whole country waited
for that change and at first and may
have seemed like it will come to
fruition Castro seized American
companies assets in Cuba and started
what he saw as improvement of the
country land redistribution universal
education / health care along with
vaccinations harsh crackdown on gangs
and racism etc however all these
improvements came at a huge cost mass
executions without trials were held
forced labor camps were established for
of travel was massively restricted and
the freedom of speech became almost
non-existent the establishments and
newspapers that supported castra the
start now suddenly realized they made a
huge mistake and many of them tried
fighting back to no avail thousands of
people were killed exiled and even more
escaped Castro had full control over the
government and could seemingly do
whatever he thought was the best for the
people but the idea of fighting a
People's Revolution to only then decide
that you alone know what the people want
seems very hypocritical nonetheless
despite the suffering and thousands of
lost profits day to day live improved
for an average Cuban however with the
biggest economy in the world now hating
you and your largest ally being across
the globe communism even though
beneficial for the average Cuban in the
short term would most definitely proved
to be a terrible choice in the long term
the Cuban people now realize they
supported a dictator and a system that
will putting it lightly over States
welcomed and still is in the last free
publication of the Bohemian newspaper it
stated in making our own revolution it
is not necessary to subject our people
to the oppression and vassalage of
Russia to make a profound social
revolution it is not necessary to
implant a system which degrades people
to the lowly levels of state serfdom to
wipe out the last vestige of freedom and
dignity this is not a genuine revolution
so let that serve as a reminder that no
matter how better the ideas of true
communism may seem from your current
standpoint in the end
hello everyone this was a very different
video compared to what I usually do on
this channel so if you didn't like it
feel free to hit that dislike button but
if you liked it let me know down in the
comments if you want to see more videos
like these or dads thank you until next
time my name is my sir